silencio bruno that's just a dumb voice
in your head disney pixar's luca is a
film about friendship and perseverance
just like luca and alberto the creators
of this film faced numerous
obstacles from pandemic restrictions to
creating never seen before technology
the lengths that went into the creation
of this film were intense
luckily with the help of their epic cast
they were able to power through but not
without multiple silencio brunos of
course
disney and pixar have created some
animated staples like monsters inc nemo
and coco luca director enrico casarosa
followed directly in their footsteps by
inspiring the creation of new
groundbreaking technology while monsters
inc brought the ability to animate soft
hair and nemo water luca animators hit a
breakthrough when it came to the smooth
transition between human skin and fish
scales the question from day one
technically how do you go from fish
scales to human skin luca's
transformations throughout the film play
a major role and the entire team knew
that they needed to be perfect if they
wanted this film to be what enrico had
envisioned they used what is called a
transformation rig which allowed them to
turn their characters invisible now you
could lay the second character in and
make him invisible and leave just the
feet and you could pick how faded you
wanted that to be or where you wanted it
to be or not be and it was like whoa
this is so cool however cool the
technology may have been it didn't come
without its difficulties the
transformation of our sea monsters and
in particular luca was one of the
biggest challenges on our film they
initiated multiple tests and even had a
painter create a gif to try and bring
the image of the transformation they had
in their head to life after the ideas
and technology were floated around not
just the effects department but the
production team and artists they finally
figured out their masterpiece with a
little help from the animation used for
coco the blending aspects of it we
actually used a little bit of technology
from coco the new technology was even
used in developing the motion of pasta
in the film how italian after getting
the scales and human skin down packed it
was time for the animators to take a
crack at the characters because of
movement and facial expressions the two
departments needed to work together in
order to make sure the expressions of
the characters matched the
transformation does it come as an
explosion of excitement or does it
happen slowly we needed to be able to
control that they took into
consideration how the character would
react to a splash of water versus a body
of water and even analyzed marine
iguanas for inspiration on their
movements this all especially came into
play when they animated what they call
the swim sequence swim was the first
time where we were really showing off
what it means to be a sea monster and a
human and to switch back and forth
between the two this is where luca makes
the decision to go to the human world
originally the scene was supposed to be
comedic but they discovered the
potential in it after uncovering the
technology they needed for the sea
monsters in this scene they even used
the horizon to show luca's inner turmoil
the horizon line is always against luka
when he's struggling and it's for him
when he's actually getting it right
despite being a sea monster enrico made
it clear that luca should always appear
not creepy whoa whoa i don't want to be
bitten by this guy in order to do this
they made sure their creations were
always lyrical and decorative and made
sure to include enrico's love for
childlike animation even the sea monster
to human transformation was meant to be
gentle isn't it great
no
it's bad and i'm not supposed to be up
here
luckily for the animators they had
impeccable concept art drawn for them
enrico translated many of his own
experiences into the film one of those
being his love for japanese animation
specifically by hayao miyazaki he sat
down with his crew and watched projects
like the castle of cagliostro and future
boy conan we watched it together we
analyzed what can limited animation
inspire us to do so that inspiration
turned into beautiful 2d concept art
that later was translated into 3d
on-screen however director of
photography david bianchi said they
wanted to make sure that 3d animations
still reflected enrico's initial vision
it still feels like a cg film but you
can sense the hand of the artists
touching it everyone puerto rosa
pretends to believe in sea monsters
while the location of puerto rosso is
based on five fishing towns on the
coastal cinque terre region of italy the
name was also a nod to japanese
animation disney released a copyright
document confirming that the name was a
play on porco rosso a film about an
italian pig pilot from the 90s aside
from japanese influence enrico also used
his love for looney tunes and took
inspiration from how the cartoon
demonstrated speed we'd have three you
know from my hand here to here to here
we would do all three of them to kind of
simulate quick speed even sean the sheep
had a part in luca in terms of how the
creators wanted to incorporate some
stop-motion vibes into the film as for
the creation of the sea monsters those
came from old renaissance maps from the
1500s and old italian sculptures they
found when they went to italy during
their pre-production research overall
enrico wanted these animations to be
unique and imperfect and even had the
computer make mistakes on purpose to
achieve his vision i love the sense that
all of our characters in some way feel
different or unusual luca's director put
his soul into the film literally the
story is loosely based on his experience
growing up in genoa with his best friend
alberto my best friend alberto was a bit
of a troublemaker alberto pushed me out
of my comfort zone and pushed me off
many cliffs metaphorically and not the
film's theme of friendship and being who
we are goes so much deeper than the
audience knows
i think he needs me
you know
i can't do it without you while the
technical aspects faced many challenges
when it came to animations the actors
also faced difficulties themselves luca
is a part of the epic collection of
films that were made during the covet 19
pandemic shout out to raya and the last
dragon the three main characters luca
alberto and julia may have been the best
of friends on screen but off-screen
their actors rarely saw one another
because of protocols some actors like
jack dylan grazer were forced to record
their voiceovers in their mom's closet
it's fine i'm not human
while he may have needed to have worked
around some sweaters and shoes his
makeshift studio seemed pretty cozy but
despite his unique studio the scenario
was still difficult for him it was
definitely a stretch for me a challenge
for me as an actor and as just a human
being not to mention he may have annoyed
his neighbors just a tad i bet my
neighbors were really freaked out about
the amount of screaming that was going
on from my house i don't know what they
were thinking as for jacob trombley who
voices luca he was a little luckier than
jack i actually started recording before
covet hit so i was able to go into the
san francisco studio and they gave me
the tour when the pandemic did arrive he
was prepared to get his closet turned
into a studio but instead was able to
safely record in a studio located in his
home city of vancouver
underdogs forever emma berman who played
julia didn't get a whole tour like jacob
but was lucky enough to record her part
in the studio as well look
that's saturn it's my favorite
they didn't get the full filming
experience but the cast still fell in
love with their characters and the story
of luca while jack and jacob just
couldn't get over how beautiful the
animation of the film turned out the
color of the sea and the sparkliness of
the sea emma fell in love and related
wholeheartedly to the character of julia
i had a really fun time playing her
because i relate to her in a lot of ways
we were both passionate about what we do
and we're also very excited and joyful
people despite their challenges the cast
and crew transported their audience off
their living room couch to what jacob
trombley described as the most perfect
vacation that's literally what porterosa
is director casarosa was able to share
his message of love and friendship with
the world and used his creative mind to
help inspire technology that will be
used and developed for many more
animations to come talk about a
groundbreaking film it's another one in
the books for disney pixar thanks for
watching